folks in the street ain't got nothing to
eat and the whole Beach milk and
Wildfire put a pause there so this is
probably intentional to be a
contradiction or to maybe to seem like a
paradox but I don't think it is a
paradox I think it's just a
contradiction he's saying people in the
street don't have any food but but the
obese are milking welfare people don't
really go hungry in America the knock on
the American political order is that the
poor robes and they're not just obese
because they're milking welfare you
could complain about welfare again
that's not totally a populist complaint
that's a little bit more of the Mitt
Romney Paul Ryan kind of stuff the
problem is that the poor in America are
obese because of the culture problems
because we don't have really Community
or political love anymore because
marriages have fallen apart because
we've got rampant drug abuse and
addiction because we've got people who
are despondent don't think they have a
future because their money's not worth
anything and they can't get any good
jobs and it's all kind of jumbled up
it's a stew of lamenting about the
political order